what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at tiff2022
i have the team behind carmen with us
right now huge congratulations like this
is quite the feat for you but our first
feature this is so incredibly ambitious
i'm very impressed thank you
so before we even kick off our
conversation here i have to ask you to
do this i have a feeling a lot of people
are going to ask you to do this in
interviews but can you give us a brief
description of what your film is about
um
well you know it's uh it first of all
it's really a story like not unlike my
my ballets um it's a story that is
told through movement and music um and
it's the story of um
an immigrant carmen who flees
the border crosses the border after the
murder of her mother
and
during the border crossing she meets
and a border patrol who's really there
against his will almost that night who
has been on a couple of tours to
afghanistan and sort of everything goes
wrong that night
they end up having to flee together
towards los angeles paul is so good in
this too i just have to say that because
he's not here right now but again a
mighty ambitious first feature for you
here
what would you say is the key to i guess
convincing the necessary parties who
grant green lights and maybe even
yourself that you were ready to direct a
feature like this ah wow well it's a lot
of work and a lot of luck um you know i
i had been shooting
dance films for for little short films
for a long time
uh this had been maturing in my head for
for some time as well and
you know i don't know i think it's how
you explain the vision and um and i
found a producer who believed in in the
idea and gave me the freedom to do it
dimitri hassan i was very very fortunate
um
yeah i mean it's it's madness you know
making a film
uh is you sort of come together it's
like building a company from scratch
with people you've never met uh and so
it's it's an insane enterprise and
especially
this one you know we were supposed to
shoot in mexico and la and we ended up
in australia and so it was quite it was
quite a journey uh but we got there were
all those moves uh pandemic related well
the last one was okay um yes last one
was to australia yeah okay well where
you landed is perfect this thing looks
absolutely i still can't get over what
you've accomplished here speaking of
which what was it about ben during your
first meeting that made you say even
though he's never directed a feature
before i feel like i'm in good hands
when this role is going to be putting a
lot on my shoulders
well
actually our first meeting was super
interesting i already knew of benjamin's
work i knew he had choreographed black
swan and i had googled him and i knew
his talent as a choreographer
and when i met him we were sitting at a
picnic table outside of ladp
and
and he like just we just talked about
the script he had sent me the script
with like some of the music and like
pictures and like inspiration like a
very complete package and i was like
this is incredible i would be so lucky
to be able to be a part of this and so
we met
and i and we we chatted about the script
and i told him all the problems that i
had with script and i was like he hates
me i was like there's no way that i'm
getting this because this was like
this was in 2018 right
2018 yeah i had done nothing except a
season of vita so i was like i'm no one
literally i'm no one i just got to la
and
and i'm just i just came and i told him
like all the issues that i have as a
mexican
you know a story about a mexican
immigrant it like is important that we
do it right so i told him all my
thoughts
and then he's so serious he's french so
he was like so serious i was like he
hates me there's no way i'm getting this
i left i called my team i was like he
hates me there's no way and then they
called me they were like he wants to see
you dance i was like well
that's gonna be a whole other thing
because i'm not a dancer
but
he was just he knows his intuition with
like people's bodies he knows how to
make everyone look good
and so it just that was the beginning of
the journey in 2018. yeah and it was
very common of you it's true you you you
came to the meeting and you were sort of
like well this is no good but i'm
interested
the idea of the movie like felt
incredible
i was like the script needs work
but i was like yeah she's the characters
was right i have so many follow-up
questions to what you just explained
first can you give us a specific example
of something you saw in the the script
and you know made you think like we can
evolve this and make it stronger i mean
honestly the script in 2018 is a
completely different movie than the one
that we made like i don't know which one
you read actually
the script that i read so this is a
reimagining of of the opera of carmen
really
the the thing that's left of like carmen
is the character because like nothing
else is
related anymore um
to me
in my brain this is like an origin story
of sorts it's like you get to meet the
character and like kind of see how she
becomes the carmen that everyone knows
in my brain the script that i read was
more
like the opera it had like the two men
fighting for her like it was more like
that
it was still very it was still closer to
it it was a lot it was very into
the drug cartels like it had a lot more
presence of like a guy in the drug
cartel that wanted to be with her and i
was like i don't want to do that i don't
want to that be like to continue to
paint mexico in that light
so yeah we got rid of the stereotypes
and the cliches
and ended up in a much more pure place
which was more personal for all of us
you know in the story we told i can't
picture the movie any other way now it's
blowing my mind to hear you describe
where you originally started with this
let's see if i can remember more of my
follow-up questions so you had just
mentioned this this first came up before
uh in the heights before scream what is
the key for you to staying committed to
a project like this for that long
because i imagine a lot of things
changed as like you know your star sword
through those really great films so many
things changed
and
the one constant was that i knew that i
needed to be a part of this movie
i knew like there was you know you just
get this gut feeling
i
knew that whatever benjamin was gonna do
was gonna be something incredible and
magical just because i had seen him work
i had already started working with him
in dance and i was like
i need like i just can't let this go and
you know there were a lot of ups and
downs like the movie kind of like died
many times and then it came back like
you know it was a long journey to get it
made
but i just knew that it was going to be
special and it was every day on set in
sydney and in broken hill
it felt like we were making art you know
and you don't feel that a lot of times
in movies and it was just the way that
ben runs the set like the energy there
would always be music playing he always
had a playlist he would yell cut and
then like the music would come on
he would like we were like doing that
dance in the desert and like there's
like footprints on the on the sand so we
had to like clean them after every take
and like ben would grab a broom and like
dance and like clean the desert like it
was just like fun and
it felt everyone involved like the
entire crew was so
into it and and and like wanting to like
help tell this story and it felt i'm
usually attracted to like unique things
you know like i want to do things that
are different and that are like pushing
the envelope and like breaking out of
the mold and that's what benjamin wanted
to do with this like his because he's a
choreographer i think he has such a
unique
way of seeing things
and
it was it was incredible and i knew it
and i just couldn't let it go
i'm glad that he didn't let me go
because like it could have you know he
could have been like i found another
carmen
and i'm glad that he didn't i had to
convince once i'd be like no no no you
gotta stay this is gonna happen yeah
yeah so melissa had just said this kind
of you know started and stopped and
started and stopped what wound up being
the key to i guess getting the official
green light and feeling like we're
actually going to really make this movie
now
uh well really bringing paul on board
paul mezcal and the timing of it and you
know we were
going to australia um actually my wife
was shooting thor in australia and
starting to look at the landscapes i had
done all the scouting in mexico spent
quite a bit of time there so i was
really informed with sort of visually
what i wanted to do and i started to
realize that the movie you know
especially because of the dreamlike
quality we could achieve it uh in
australia
and from that moment on
uh
you know the movie happened we went
there and we were in pre-production i
couldn't believe it at the time really
to be honest we had to do the 14-day
quarantine in australia all of us yeah
the mandatory like
military takes you to the hotel
locks you in a room doesn't give you a
key that
we all did that
it's important well worth it
so with the treadmill
i did have a treadmill with a treadmill
okay
it's important if you're in lockdown
mode so you're experimenting quite a bit
here with uh movement music and dance is
there anything you wanted to do in that
respect that made you think like this is
so incredibly ambitious that i don't
know if it's going to work but we have
to at least try it you know just to talk
about that for me it was just the
natural thing to do the movie is exactly
what i wanted to do the luck that i have
is that people allowed me to make a film
that
had that kind of freedom i think in
expression how i how the story is
expressed how you know
and um
yeah no it was um i think it's it's
really it's it's my film it looks like
my film and
it doesn't i don't think that it's
ambitious i think it's exactly what it's
supposed to be you know
i love the different perspectives it's
like business as usual and i'm like how
did you do all that movie magic was
there any particular scene in the movie
that made both of you go like that right
there that's going to be the most
challenging scene to shoot and then in
the end is that actually the most
challenging scene or did something wind
up catching you by surprise during
production there were many challenging
scenes to shoot because we we
i mean the dances alone were all
you know one sequence shot no cuts
camera was choreographed around melissa
um and we shot them as you know i mean
yeah they were and we had rain and we
had you know we had some some issues
there there were a lot of uh difficult
but everything worked out you know yeah
everything worked out in the end there
were a lot of long
takes you know a lot of long like no
cutting
clear out the whole crew hide because
it's like the camera and the actors 360.
and there was a beautiful like
freedom we had a lot of um
like ben gave us a lot of freedom to
improvise
and so a lot of like the things were
just things that we were feeling in the
moment that would kind of come up
and
like i remember the masilda scene that
we shot
that that's that was like a magical
moment that's really that was
rossi's first scene on set and you know
it's seven minutes and uh it's not this
you you two are incredible and so is the
city cam operator because frankly
uh i actually didn't block i blocked the
beginning of the scene and then i said
you know just and i actually didn't tell
any of you i wasn't gonna call cut yeah
um and it just went on and it was just
magic and that's the scene that ended up
in the film yeah the first take
incredible
it was it was we were in the in the club
and they everyone kind of went behind
the scenes there was no one in the club
the club was empty it was rossi and me
and uh and our camera operator our
steadicam operator who was incredible
like he learned to dance basically you
taught him how to like dance with the
camera
and i remember like we shot this scene
and then it was in spanish mind you okay
ben doesn't speak spanish
so he trusted us a lot with like the
spanish of it all
we
we do the scene in spanish
we he yells cut finally everyone comes
out and like so many people are crying
and and it was incredible because i was
like how are you all crying if you don't
even speak spanish like none of you
speak spanish and everyone just kind of
like
got it and that was a very magical
moment
on onsen no no
it truly it truly was and i think for me
it was always important to create i
think coming from the theater always
important to create the atmos an
atmosphere that i could really see on
the set
that looked like my film that created a
kind of ambiance that i that i was
looking for
and i think that in that setting
particularly i think it was very helpful
i mean we really felt like you were
there yeah totally
then he did this other thing
so i'm dancing by myself carmen is like
kind of comes into the club and she's
dancing by herself and she and then
masilda starts clapping and she looks
over and she's like oh my god i didn't
see you well ben
called in marina who plays my mom who's
dead
and they and calls her in and sits her
beside rosie so when i'm i'm dancing and
i turn around i see both of them
and i literally like i get just i get
goosebumps just thinking about that
moment again because that's the kind of
thing that he did as a director he liked
to like surprise us and that just like
helped me a lot in that scene because it
was such a long scene that we did over
and over again that it just like kind of
refueled me just seeing
her
beside like i'm dancing for my mom and
then all of a sudden like i turn around
and she's there like an apparition it
was like such a an incredible moment
yeah marina was always uh i could call
an hour before i have this idea can you
come can you be there should you be
there um but uh that was that was that
was fun to we actually ended up keeping
her yeah in the in the scene she's there
it's so funny no one has asked why this
woman is there in that moment like yeah
no one no one no because it's very clear
it makes sense yeah
you really feel the power of everything
that that seven minute warner is it i
was watching the whole film very very
moved that particular moment just like
absolutely takes your breath away
it's really something else
um i want to bring back talking a little
bit about paul here so you guys prepared
with dancing professionally for the
first time i'm sure there are a lot of
conversations and pre-production but
what is something that the two of you
discovered on set when you were actually
working as seen partners together that
all the prep in the world never would
have helped you achieve
um
i think paul and i are very similar in
that we are
perfectionists like we like kind of
pushing ourselves
and so
it was
from the moment that we started dancing
together it just felt like oh okay you
got me i got you we're gonna do these
crazy lifts we're gonna do them and i
trust you to like not kill me
and it was like
okay we did it once and you know holly
who was ben's assistant that was like
rehearsing with us all the time while he
was doing director stuff
um
she would be like okay you're good and
we'd both be like no we're going again
we didn't that we didn't nail it we're
doing it again and we would just go and
go and go and it was a beautiful thing
to feel that support i really
i cannot like i tell him all the time
and i told him all the time and i will
tell him again when i see him today like
his support he was the best teammate he
was the best person to have as a partner
he was the perfect aiden
it's it's crazy to think like how we got
to him because like i had been
rehearsing with other actors already
you know like someone else was supposed
to play aidan we had been dancing
together then it fell apart and then
finally he comes in and it was just
perfect like i can't even imagine it
being with anyone else he was like
the most supportive
and he would cost i was so
i was you know it was my first time away
from my family christmas and new year's
in australia the other end of the world
i was i was by myself i was feeling like
sad and i also was feeling the pressure
of this movie and like it's called
carmen and i'm playing carmen and like
the character's so famous and like
people have all these expectations i
just had i felt like i had a lot on my
back
and both ben
and paul
just kept me sane and kept me like
feeling like i could
i could do this and i could and i could
count on them to
like remind me that i was doing well
because sometimes you need someone to
tell you like you're doing okay because
you feel like you're
doing awful you know
also you know
it was a lot of trust to trust me
because i think we were things were a
little different how
i was also i'm so used to sort of paying
attention to things that happen
spontaneously naturally on set and take
advantage of them and
so it was also it's a little bit you
know experimental to be honest which
which took like a lot of trust but last
thing i want to say how incredible
of course is singing where you're
dancing is in the film and how really
melissa is not really like a dancer or
taking dance classes or it's really
phenomenal i i genuinely feel and i love
those those girls that you're dancing
with um in the dance in the desert but
you you bring like a kind of a
response to the moment and like an
attack that is like so incredible that i
even i think is we did we did that
greatest thing that sequence in the
desert which was a whole thing because
it was raining we couldn't shoot you
know safety lightning whatever it took
us a really long time to actually get to
it and i was so nervous because it was
me
dancing with
five or six girls from the sydney dance
company you know like the official like
the best dancers in sydney basically and
me and i have to like be in the middle
and i was so terrified and i don't know
what happened that day that
after one take ben comes and he's like
how did you do that and i was like what
do you mean he's like
you
how did you dance like that i was like i
don't know i don't know what's it good
is it bad and he was like it was amazing
i was like oh thank god but i don't know
like something just kind of happened
whenever the camera rolled you were like
you were there dancing can confirm in
the final product like my brain can't
compute this whole idea that you're not
a professional dancer after what i've
seen you do
it's breaking my heart i have to let you
go and i haven't even asked anything
about nicholas patel but you know what i
have to do now i'm using shoes as
currency for scoops during tiff 2022 i
am wearing scream shoes right now
you can't answer anything i'm going to
ask but i'm going to try anyway those
are the coolest shoes thank you i'll
take that i did this with someone
yesterday and they said that and then
give me nothing so you'll be okay giving
me nothing right now is there anything
you can tease about what it means to be
chased by ghost face in a big city
instead of woodsboro or any other kind
of suburban town
um
it's
like 20 times more mortifying
it's it's awful
because you you also see how
in a city like new york city everyone is
kind of
doing their own thing and someone is
screaming for help and no one will come
to their help no one come to help them
you know like everyone's kind of like
i'm not getting into that so it's
mortifying because you you're chased by
ghost place but you also see like
humanity and like
how how that reacts you know in a
situation like that anyway i think i've
already probably said too much but
as someone who lived in new york city
for a very very long time that is one of
my biggest fears and that's what i was
hoping you would say yeah so i love it
but back to carmen huge huge huge
congratulations and just because i have
to say it again i know you're friendly
with him nicholas patel is hands down
one of the best composers working in
this industry and you very much see that
coming through in your film
congratulations to everybody out there
keep an eye out for carmen we'll see you
soon with more tip 2022 interviews